hey everybody from the Resident Evil
team this is Matt Matt skills Mike kills
is my middle name I guess that means
that your last name is Mike I think
you're overthinking it man well we're
about to watch some umbrella cores game
play here we have the Bravo on Alpha
Team getting suited up for battle some
good gear you're gonna wear that I won't
be caught dead wearing that no we'll
find out and with a few moments
remaining the teams are hammering out
their strategy using the tactical icons
yeah and it looks like alphas a little
bit all over the place they better get
on the same page or this may not end
well both teams start up cautiously
obviously winning this first round is
going to be big right elf separates
early owl and Hawk are swinging out west
side and we've got Eagle going it's solo
through the ventilation shaft among
zombies proceeding with thought if I
hear gunfire alphas make contact gunfire
the first floor hallway Eagle spots the
rest the alpha team they're attacking
from the middle needles gonna go for
cover here get that element of surprise
a bead on bear oh nice and Bravo's last
one oh nice take that back intense
point-blank firefight opting me the
smart move to cover that's one Bravo
Team down intelligent use of cover right
there and alpha looking for the next
target spotted they both take cover
using that she'll come on there's a nice
box up and down yeah alphas gonna swing
around here
look he's lost a couple oh and that's
the end of the row dead start up a new
round yeah it looks like they're in sync
now teamwork is gonna be vital they used
it to dominate the last round let's see
if it was a fluke contact grenade out
giggles all right and he should try to
flank in a hurry all the treads were
just and still taking out a point blame
eautifully executed shot gonna point
link now shotguns the perfect weapon for
that range but he's got a badly damaged
jammer right there well that's another
alpha team number down can they turn the
tables he's gonna try and close the gap
here and he's taking cover still got a
three-on-two situation here can Bravo
even the odds fire in the hole
drying him out of cover can't seem to
take him out though he's gonna have to
go in for the kill contact alpha making
their retreat but it's jammers busted
and he's running right into a group of
zombies
yeah Eagles in trouble now
Buster jamaran I hear he's delicious
well the zombies have taken notice now
he's gonna have to deal with both the
oppose of Tina
Edna zombies hard but not impossible
he's a veteran he made a well zombie
fighter now and that's gonna put outside
a disadvantage here comes the cavalry
they're gonna have to open that shutter
contact here come and it's opening
things all here Bravo sauce done one two
one two now one more data Bravo
so you want one situation now talking in
not good for problem hearing aid rushing
in for the kill
open season I'll forego for the sneak
attack we go on nervous around garrison
and mash say good night oh he only got a
to far for the shotgun too far shun the
back though
Bravo gets the first kill Bravo turning
up the heat and just like that two men
down now it's one-on-one Alpha Team
sticking together it's moving behind the
shutter contact two numbers Bravo only
just opening up on each other alpha
returns fire again moving together as a
team same strategy as before alpha is a
little bit ahead here so they're gonna
give confident but I wouldn't get too
cocky because Bravo can still turn the
tables well it looks like they got let
me waiting for at the bottom of the
stairs steady aim of down he goes only
two more Bravo two numbers left put me
on to situation travel returning fire
but they're outnumbered by alpha grenade
incoming and Eagle evades like a champ
incoming enemy fire and this is a
popular spot it's gonna get a to be a
real meat grinder soon looks like both
teams gonna try and find another way
around the shutters open contact here is
he gonna try to come out with a brainer
no brainer
no jammer Avella falling back often
moving in a grenade alpha falling back
not in great condition an officer down
that's gonna hurt me birthday contact
Eagle may want to try sneaking through
the ventilation [ __ ] I think should be
careful here is another guy
Fox is in there takes him out over
ventilate shame on you okay oh they're
just firing firing up all cylinders well
of course he did yeah an eagle think
she's Rambo he's running like crazy you
should be a little more careful there's
Fox so take him up from behind you know
on to the last man standing in the way
of victory he's pulling out his no he's
going to his trusty beretta die
you are dead crazy that's what they talk
about when they talk about competitive
shooters Matt oh yeah well that's going
to be it for us today everybody thanks a
lot for joining us we'll see you next
time